the media has been enthralled by
a story by a certain story and they're
very excited about it they're having a
field day uh very very excited about
this
the story as reported in the Daily Mail
repeated by every corporate media Outlet
and I'll read you with Daily Mail
reports and then you can I mean every
corporate media outlet has put out a
report just like this uh which is
phrased almost exactly the same way like
a cut and paste job
so here it is
one of the funders of the film sound of
Freedom has been arrested for kidnapping
a child according to court records
Fabian Marta 51 was one of thousands of
donors who gave funds for the production
of the film based on former Department
of Homeland Security agent Tim Ballard's
efforts against child trafficking
the St Louis Missouri Resident was Char
was charged with felony child kidnapping
last month
the sound of Freedom movie tackle is a
very tough subject and took
extraordinary effort to bring it to
movie theaters that's uh from Marta who
wrote that on Facebook and now deleted
post
as reported by Newsweek
I'm proud to have been a small part of
it if you see the movie look for Fabian
Marta and family at the very end of the
credits
and sure enough uh uh Freddie Marta is
in the credits of the film and in some
cases that's the way it's been phrased
in the headlines yeah there have been
headlines saying uh funder of sound of
freedom
uh charged with you know child
trafficking child kidnapping and then
there are other headlines that say uh
man who appears in credits of of sound
of Freedom charged with uh child
kidnapping
uh he could face 10 years in prison now
so that's the headline and again the
media is very excited about this I mean
they're getting these reports out
everywhere and you look at the leftists
on social media they're gloating about
it they're happy about it they're very
happy that this happened uh they're very
happy about the story this is a story
allegedly about a child who's kidnapped
and they they the left cannot contain
their Glee they they can't even pretend
to contain it they're excited
um
here's the part they don't highlight
first of all this film had 6 000 people
who funded it
uh with an average of 500 bucks each
so Fabian Marta probably you know I
don't think we know the exact amount
that he gave but everyone you know if
he's around the average and he gave 500
bucks or so
or that's all he would have needed to
give to count as a funder
um
so that is the big time funder someone
who gave 500 bucks to the film
the second point is that according to
follow-up reports on this story Fabian
Marta is a landlord
Who provided lodging to a woman and her
child and that woman is involved in a
custody dispute
and that's the story
now what are the details from there did
Marta actually do anything wrong was he
involved in some kind of conspiracy what
are the details with the child and the
custody dispute and who's in the right
and who's in the wrong
I have no idea I have the slightest idea
I don't know anything else and I don't
think the media knows anything else and
you know it's it's a very complicated
situation
but this is
we know at least some kind of obscure
custody type dispute between a woman a
child a father presumably and a landlord
and one of the people in that involved
in this dispute uh gave a few hundred
bucks to a film
in other words there's no story here
it's clear the left is giving up their
morals in any Common Sense there's no
better time than to build a daily habit
of prayer and meditation building a
habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you're thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being Hollow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine it can help you do the same
download the app for free at hollow.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
and track your progress along the way
not sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
available on the Hello app for brief
daily readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and
even some world-class athletes with how
low you can customize a personal prayer
plan that works for you listen wherever
you are with downloadable offline
sessions using hello to connect with
others who share your beliefs and values
can provide a sense of belonging support
and Foster a sense of community as well
ultimately we'll learn how we can become
better individuals in spite of today's
broken worlds we strive to become more
like Christ in our daily lives through
prayer fasting and giving download
hello.com Matt Walsh should get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at howlo.com
slash Matt Walsh
you know the fact that a guy is a
landlord and he's involved in this
dispute and there's a custody dispute
and he gave 500 bucks to uh to the sound
of Freedom a few years ago that's not a
story that's not anything
okay you you would hear that if you
didn't have the media's framing of it
and you hear that and someone tells you
that it's like imagine
someone just ran into your living room
and you had no you had no reference no
frame of reference
and they just told you this story guess
what listen to this you're not going to
believe it why what's going on
so there's a guy
who's a landlord for a woman who has a
child and they're in a custody dispute
and he's just been arrested for
kidnapping because he's involved and he
and and he he gave 500 bucks to a movie
that deals with child trafficking and he
that's the story can you believe it
if you heard that you say what okay
what's the relevance of that why is this
Headline News why are you so excited
about it
it's not a story at all but the left is
very sort of excited about it because
they see it as something that somehow
discredits the movie
which of course even if like the worst
version of this story was true when you
read the headlines you're supposed to
imagine in your head that Fabian Marta
is when you hear investor or funder of
film you're imagining like this
millionaire who gave millions of dollars
to make the film and when you hear that
he's involved in kidnapping you you are
supposed to imagine that he actually
physically kidnapped a child and stole
the child and and all of that
and that's not apparently what actually
happened but even if it did
that wouldn't the movie's based on a
true story about it's an it's an
anti-child Trafficking movie that
doesn't discredit the point of the what
so does that mean that now child
trafficking is good or something
so even in the worst version of the
story doesn't discredit the film
and it especially doesn't given what we
actually know to be true about about
this story
but it does raise the question of why is
the left so desperate what do you have
against this movie
like the movie didn't blame you for
anything it didn't what do you what do
you have against it
maybe you've seen the movie and uh and
it's hard for me to believe that you
even watched objectively and you know or
that you objectively analyzed it but
even if you think that oh the acting
isn't very good the script's not good
whatever
what do you have against it
why
why are you so desperate to find some
reason to discredit it
um
so really this this raises a lot of
questions about you why would you see
it's those of us who are normal we can't
even put ourselves in this mentality
there's a movie out there it's an
anti-child traffic in movie
um it's a it's a movie about kids being
rescued from trafficking
maybe you want to see the movie maybe
you don't
um
maybe it's the kind of subject matter
that's uh too upsetting for you so you
don't want to watch the movie you know I
know there's many many people that are
I've talked to said well I can't even I
don't want to watch the movie because
the subject matter is upsetting I just
don't want to sit there and watch it so
maybe whatever your perspective is
but why would you like hate the very
idea of the movie why would you have
some kind of agenda against the movie
it's a very good question
and all of the potential answers to
those questions
are um not very fattering flattering for
the people on the left
it says a lot about them
and none of it is good
we could leave it at that hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there